Вітаю вас дорогі друзі Я думаю що
останні два тижні були дуже буремними і
небезпечними для України для її
європейської перспективи і потребують
негайної і
компетентної реакції від всіх гілок
влади і почати Я хотів би слів подяки
дуже міцної солідарності і і
відповідальної позиції яку
продемонстрували справжні українські
журналісти продемонструвавши
Солідарність коли була
спроба
тиску
слідкування наїзду на
журналістів хотів подякувати громадським
активістам які так само реагували на
незаконні дії силовиків уже зараз по
відношенню до активіст
Ну і третя Це була взагалі феєрічні дії
силовиків з дбр з бебу з офісу
Генерального прокурора з СБУ які
фінально завершили кошмаряння бізнесом
епічним арештом одного з
трьох голів інвестиційних банків пана
Ігоря Мазепа
перше це була атака на єдність бо
сьогодні єдність була і залишається на
701ший день війни Ключовим
фактором збереження держави і нашої
майбутньої
Перемоги Я закликаю щоб
ми забезпечили цю Єдність і об'єдналися
навколо збройних сил а Хочу наголосити
що саме бізнес не тільки створює робочі
місця не тільки сплачує податки за
рахунок яких ми утримуємо збройні сили
України бо за рахунок зовнішньої
допомоги фінансової Ми не маємо права
згідно до міжнародних правил витрачати
це на фінансування збройних сил а бізнес
в абсолютній своїй більшості так само як
і український народ волонтерить і
допомагає армії на відміну До речі
від силовиків для того щоби переконатися
в цьому просто подивитися скільки дбр
порушила кримінальних справ проти
військовослужбовців це вимірюється
десятками
тисяч дбр які втікла в перші
години до на захід країни зрадивши
державу і сьогодні рішеннями
Личаківського суду вони Вони все ще не
вийшли з тих лісів штампує тиск на
бізнес а по-друге інвестори які і без
того бо частина з них є іноземними І
абсолютно має обмежене мотивацію
патріотизм і сьогодні не можуть
зрозуміти і налякані силовими діями
коли бізнес не може захистити себе і не
впевнений в власній безпеки от що для
мене є символом цього подивиться Ігоря
Мазепу затримали на
кордоні по дорозі на
давоз де українські представники
українська влада численна делегація яка
коштом державного бюджету або коштом
спонсорів була направлена до довосу
розповідали який красивий український
будинок
реальних інвесторів які їхали для того
щоб провести переговори і залучити кошти
інвестиції в конкретні проекти на
території України затримують без санкції
суду заарештовують без санкції суду
обшукують без санкції суду і вибиваючи
двері в її офіс перешкоджають нормальній
діяльності підприємства і справа не в
Мазепі точніше не тільки в Мазепі і не в
бізнесі точніше не тільки в бізнесі
сьогодні
98% українців живе надіями на майбутнє
але дуже швидке членство України в ЄС та
нато
критеріями роботою яку має досягнути
Україна є копенгагенські критерії і там
є і верховенство право там є і
незалежність судів там є і інвестиційний
клімат там є і антикорупційні кроки І
все
те що переконливо
продемонстрували наші силовики що вони
боряться з цим в
Україні Я Хочу наголосити що виконавці
не змінилося от як вони були в 13му році
оце банда Януковича на чолі з
заступником Голови адміністрації
президента з юридичних питань паном
портновим який повністю контролював
силовиків і правоохоронні органи Так
його друзі і партнери зараз намагаються
робити те саме ви що думаєте їх імена
невідомі на кожній зустрічі з послами на
кожній зустрічі з нашими партнерами
нам називають ці імена і запитують Коли
вони будуть відправлені геть до свого
патрона коли будуть санкції проти
портнова які запроваджені американцями а
нашим щось дуже перешкоджає і заважає це
реалізувати і потрібні зараз коли вже
температура сягнула точки кипіння
Влада зрозуміла що треба зробити якісь
кроки от Я
закликаю не робить кроки як сценарій
фільму як
піарівські події яка мають просто
заспокоїти людей Бо нам потрібні не
круглі столи і не Ради з шести
підприємців А нам потрібні системні
інституційні зміни які
зафіксують права і свободи
громадянина і
підприємства Наша команда пропонує
суспільству низку кроків які називаються
план невідкладних дій для захисту
інвестицій і бізнес-клімату в Україні я
не можу сказати що це є повністю
комплексний документ ми його до працюємо
але я дуже сподіваюся що ті пропозиції
які зараз виносяться на
обговорення і учасниками
бізнес-спільноти і
бізнесо-омбудсменам і бізнесовими
асоціаціями і навіть представниками
уряду і навіть офісом президента Які цим
піклуються
це принесе набагато більш системний
результат ніж рішення Ради національної
безпеки і оборони мені як п'ятому
президенту не дуже коректно обговорювати
РНБО но я думаю що Ніна Петрівна зможе
викласти свою компетентну і неупереджену
позицію Отже переходимо до пропозицій до
конкретики пропозиція перша це
є перезавантаження бюро економічної
безпеки за зразком коли ми формували
набу сап і вищий антикорупційний суд
нагадаю що всі кадрові пропозиції
включно з ваксом були
сформовані до завершення моєї
каденції мають бути
присутні компетентні і авторитетні
іноземні
експерти мають бути присутні ретельній
між народний і громадський контроль і
мають бути комісія яка буде сформована
за участю іноземних експертів які мають
право вирішального голосу та право вето
на кандидатури і мають бути Громадська
рада
доброчесності через яку пройде
переатестацію всі працівники
бебу і комісія зробить оцінку
кваліфікаційно професійного рівня
компетентності
працівників
бебу без перезавантаження а не просто
зміни
керівника не буде ні ефективної роботи
бебу ні довіри довіри до беб до дбр і до
прочого тому що Довіра є ключове
подивиться аргументації дбр прокуратури
і бебо в Україні і в світі ніхто не
повірив
а голосу Ігоря Мазепи і маніфесту 42 і
бізнес-спільнотам і журналістам повірили
всі Без довіри Нічого не робиться тому
перезавантаження зараз є
абсолютно
безальтернативни для чого створювався
беп і тут ми переходимо до другого кроку
беб створювався для того щоби тільки не
смійтеся захистити бізнес для того щоби
СБУ для того щоби нацполіція для того
щоб дбр для того щоби всі починаючи від
Я не знаю від пожежників до офіса
генпрокурора не могли нагарматний
постріл наблизиться До бізнесу всю
інформацію яку Вони виявляють вони мали
передати в нову структуру яка повинна
було мати в першу чергу аналітичні
функції не треба кошмарити бізнес Не
треба приїжджати і робити Маскі Шоу ти
прийшов Ти вже знаєш що іде в нас уже
21й рік 24 X століття 24й рік і тому
забрати будь-яке можливість по не своїй
підслідності в офісі генпрокурора в СБУ
в нацполіції в дбр та інших внутрішніх
органах право порушувати або реєструвати
в ее
єдкрі відповідні провадження і
розслідувати такі провадження і на
сьогоднішній день ми придумали ефективні
механізми яким чином це робити От якщо в
тебе є будь-які матеріали щодо
діяльності або порушень закону суб'єктів
господарювання або суб'єктів
підприємницької діяльності ти протягом
24 годин Маєш передати ці матеріали в
беб там буде відповідна оцінка і
реєстрація провадження якщо же ти не
передав і робиш спробу незаконно
зареєструвати справу не своєї
підслідності Як правило це має або
політичну складову як в справі Мазепи
або корупційну складову як в справі
Мазепи друзі це не круглими столами і не
радами треба врегульовувати це треба
регульовувати
законом все що у вас є передайте в беп а
беп несе відповідальність за всебічну і
повноцінну позицію не передав навіть
якщо робив спробу зареєструвати
провадження справа автоматично
закривається офіс прокурора не має право
формувати процесуальних
керуючих якщо справа зареєстрована не по
підслідності друзі Я прошу вибачення за
такі складні юридичні розмови але за
цими розмовами є безпека кожного з вас
бо мова йдеться не тільки про
підприємців а мова йдеться про робочі
місця мова йдеться про податки і
врешті-решт про безпеку держави тому
Слідчий суддя навіть яму до якого
прийшло відповідне подання по не його
підслідності не має право давати дозвіл
розглядати справу дозвіл на ведення
обшуків дозвіл на проведення виїмки
дозвіл
на запобіжний захід дозвіл на будьщо
прокурор ще раз підкреслюю не призначає
процесуальних керуючих в справі в разі
порушення
підслідності далі ми бачимо на
сьогоднішній день
позасудово або з суттєвим порушенням
процедури коли силовики можуть прийти на
підприємство і зупинити його діяльність
і для цього існує безліч способів
починаючи від арешту активів і
закінчуючи е правом недопус працівників
підприємства до своїх активів починаючи
від роботи держаудіту і закінчуючи
пожежниками починаючи від
держспоживслужби і закінчуючи будь-ким
будь ласка ви не маєте права зупиняти
роботу підприємства якщо у вас є
будь-які правовідносини до суду і в суді
находьте аргументацію якщо ви вирішуєте
це по рішенню суду це є абсолютно
європейська модель яка намі буде
прийнятна то Отже всіх силовиків всіх
правоохоронних і контролюючі органи
треба позбавити права і можливості
зупиняти бізнес тому що ви не ви
наносите суттєві збитки Я не знаю мені
сказали що навіть цією зупинкою Конкорда
збитки були нанесені такі що перевищують
навіть
інкримінуємо суму збитків 7 млн яка е
йому була пред'явлена і в цих умовах
категорично заборонено арештовувати
грошові кошти на рахунках підприємств
грошові кошти не є до не є доказом
речовим доказом і грошові кошти не
можуть
Бути От ми хочемо їх заарештувати для
забезпечення майбутньої конфіскації ні
бо є Конституція і ви можете
конфіскувати коли є рішення суду а а
рештом грошових коштів ви перешкоджаєте
або унеможливлюєте
роботу суб'єкта
господарювання Ми також наполягаємо на
тому щоби ці кошти мали бути можливість
використаний для сплати правової
допомоги адвокатів а також сплати
застави якщо власники
підприємства готові піти на це також не
можуть арешти накладатися на майно або
на кошти е безстроково от Якщо у нас до
двох місяців є запобіжні заходи щодо
обмеження волі або застави так само на
два місяці на не більше накладається
арешт на майно і активи і якщо треба
продовжувати ідить далі до суду і робить
свої аргументи У нас є випадки коли на
5птьчотири 7 років наклалися арешти і
вони потім сидять нічого не роблять не
проводять слідчих дій і
сьогодні активи інвесторів заарештовані
ми Ми також наголошуємо що ніяких більше
обшуків вилучень затримань в рамках так
званої 208 статті Тобто це коли є
негайна необхідність виявляється вони
можуть діяти без рішення суду друзі мої
208 стаття це лише про злочини проти
особи мається на увазі вбивство
згвалтування якщо людина оттримається
безпосередньо на місці злочину або
злочини проти
держави тероризм де теж людина
затримується на місці злочину Якщо у вас
є обґрунтовані підозри до суду
переконуйте суд получайте ордер І лише
після цього це робить це стовідсоткова
норма європейського законодавства і ми
аж ніяк не можемо будувати тут путінську
агресивну диктаторську державу коли
силовіки є головні в цій країні і
тиснуть на бізнес на жаль сьогодні 24
лютого 22 року яскраво продемонструвало
коли
силовики і СБУ і дбр і інші силові
віідмства здриснули з Києва а Кияни в
тому числі бізнес взяли зброю до рук і
почали боронити місто не обов'язково зі
зброєю хтось годував добровольців хтось
одягав добровольців хтось надавав
медичну допомогу хтось надавав послуги
хтось купував машини але захищали і У
вас нема права і Нема навіть моральної
якогось духу для того щоб Таким чином
поводитись з бізнесом без цього говорити
про інвестиційний або бізнес-клімат
марно наступний крок це є розмір застави
от розмір застави для економічних
злочинів не може
перевищувати розмір імовірної
шкоди якщо підозрюється обґрунтовано
неоґрунтовано що людина нанесла шкоду на
5 мльн розмір застави не може
перевищувати 5 млн чому Бо якщо навіть
людина не
дотримається підозрюваний або затриманий
не дотримається умов запобіжного заходу
і
буде десь там втче то держава
конфіскувавши заставу до державного
бюджету вже і одразу без довгих судових
процедур компенсує всі витрати А при
цьому продовжуть правові дії по
відношенню до людини яка порушила
запобіжний захід Отже ні за яких
обставин розмір застави не може
перевищувати ці позиції Тим більше що у
нас сьогодні є величезна кількість
рішень Європейського Суду з прав людини
в тому числі пам'ятаєте рішення по
директору заводу кузняно-рибальському
шандрі по генералу павловському де вони
вимушені були іти до Європейського Суду
з прав людини і чомусь це дуже тихо
пройшло коли єспл прийняв рішення про
суттєве порушення конвенції з прав
людини коли їм давали застави по
півмільярда Коли їм давали тортуру коли
вони Без вини сиділи півроку
в в'язниці А зараз А зараз держава
Україна за рахунок коштів держави
дежавного бюджету їм по рішенню єспл
компенсує їх втрати Я дуже пишаюся що і
шандр І Павловський і багато інших пішли
і всі ці кошти до останньої копійки
віддали збройним силам України А скажіть
будь ласка у нас нанесена шкода
державному бюджету і шкода яка
вимірюється сотнями мільйонів гривень і
наближається до да А ви знаєте а з кого
компенсується втрати державного
бюджету на виплати по рішенням єспл Мені
здається абсолютно очевидно мають
компенсувати з власної кишені ти хто
винні і хто допустили порушення
конвенції з прав людини Отже я хочу вам
наголосити Ви знаєте скільки стягнуто
Судді які приймали незако ні рішення під
тиском влади з прокурорів які подавали і
підписували подання на застосування
подібних е заходів які призвели до
тортур ноль і ми маємо запровадити
відповідальність силовиків якщо твоє
рішення
скасовано судом вищої істанції або
верховним судом це підстави для
дисциплінарного стягнення із прокурорів
і суддів якщо же твоє рішення скасоване
і присуджене рішенні Європейського Суду
з прав людини це гарантовано тягне щоби
з твоєї кишені з твоєї зарплати
вилучалося компенсація коштів в
державному бюджеті перше а для суддів
була безумовною підставою
для звільнення з посади і це наш
наступний слайд коли ми чітко розклали
яким чином це має виглядати причому у
людини яка
постраждала буде право подати до суду на
компенсацію вже
йому шкоди яка нанесена незаконними
діями представника в суддіх і
правоохоронних органів і тоді Наступного
разу коли роздасться з Високого кабінету
телефонний дзвінок з вимогою
заарештувати з
безпрецедентним заставою без будь-яких
підстав і суддя буде стояти в позиції
чого бажаєте то у суді з'явиться позиція
Я не хочу в майбутньому бути звільненим
або платити з власної
кишені шкоду яка буде
відшкодована це лише основна і левова
частина пропозицій які нами розроблено
Ми запрошуємо всіх до дискусії
відповідні матеріали з текстами і
проектами рішень будуть надіслані всім
зацікавленим особам Я запрошую бізнес до
абсолютно компетентного професійного
державницького патріотичного діалогу для
того щоб ми захистили європейський вибір
України для того щоби ті переговори які
ми маємо розпочати в березні дуже
швидко Були опрацьовані для того щоби
Україна е була набагато ближче до
відповідності копенгагенським критеріям
які є умовою нашого членства в
Європейському Союзі і в НАТО а зараз я
хочу запросити до слова Ніну Петрівну
южаніну людину яка і в нашій фракції і в
Верховній Раді повністю відповідає за
взаємодії з бізнесом за податкову
політику і я хочу їй подякувати за ту
величезну роботу яку з 14-го по 19 роки
Ніна Петрівна вжила для того щоби кожен
з вас пам'ятає наскільки було змінені
умови ведення бізнесу
маскішоустоп автоматичне повернення ПДВ
величезна кількість ініціатив якуї зараз
треба не просто повернутися до них але й
вдосконалити забезпечити ефективність за
истити Ніна потрівна Дякую Петро
олексівич Я хочу вам ще раз
продемонструвати цей документ рішення
Ради національної безпеки і оборони про
невідкладні заходи із забезпечення
економічної безпеки на період дії
правового режиму воєнного стану я
говорила сьогодні з юристами які сказали
що насправді це явка з повинною це
свідчить про те що закон в Україні не
працює і
насправді
ті хто готував навіть цей документ мали
усвідомлювати Що принесе даний документ
і як він буде оцінений саме юристами і
правниками так Точно не можна замінити
цими змістовними зустрічами за
ініціативи Генерального прокурора
виконання законів тому що після цього
рішення був круглий стіл де нібито знову
намагалися врегулювати в ручному режимі
якісь питання із знову пообіцяти щось
бізнесу чому ми продемонстрували всі
слайди і ви Петро Олексійович досить
детально розповіли тому що вся
пропозиція яка зараз була вам
представлена вона побудована на якісній
змінні і необхідні зміні роботи бюро
економічної безпеки це тим чим ми жили
по будучи у владі це те що має країна
обов'язково виконати для того щоби не
всі право охоронні органи здійснювали
перевірки і приходили до бізнесу а
справді працював один єдиний орган тобто
пройшло 5ть років ми повертаємося знову
до цього ж самого питання незважаючи на
те що цей орган створений він почав
працювати але він працює як говорить
переважна більшість бізнесу ще гірше чим
податкова міліція в часів Януковича
Клименка Ну Це звісно озна чає що ті
першочергові Заходи які запропоновані на
всіх інших слайдах зможуть спрацьовувати
тільки тоді коли ми якісно відреформуємо
бюро економічної безпеки і це перший
крок який наша країна має зробити і і те
що маємо в перший день засідання
парламенту приймати вже підготовлені
зміни для того щоби справді пере
провести конкурсний відбір керівництва з
залученням іноземних спеціалістів які
не дадуть можливості знову знайти свого
який буде виконувати ту ж саму роботу що
й виконувалися ці роки і керівників
департаментів які також мають пройти
через такий високий конкурсний відбір
щодо решти працівників насправді вони
мають проходити
зараз такий собі
кваліфікаційний від перегляд чи оцінку в
з ну комісією і громадською радо яка має
працювати в цьому органі Це нам дасть
можливість насправді очиститися від
великої кількості працівників які просто
перекочувались із СБУ з податкової
міліції серед них можливо є спеціалісти
але вони мають продемонструвати це через
пройти через ці Жернова для того щоби
довести що вони відповідають професійним
вимогам які пред'являються до
новоствореного органу і на Насправді це
дуже важливий момент який після чого
потрібно далі змінювати роботу бюро
економічної безпеки і в чому вона має
полягати коли запрацюють всі інші
пропозиції які ми запропонували звісно
ми будували свою роботу про те що
підслідність беб виняткова виключна вони
займаються економічними злочинами Вони
мають бути єдиними в країні для цього
звісно ми маємо розуміти а як може
побудована їх робота бути і тут
включається те що всі звикли говорити що
це аналітичний орган який має володіти
великою кількісті інформацією А що це
таке це спеціальні алгоритми роботи
побудовані на ризикоорієнтованому
підході І абсолютно точно
що до здійснення будь яких дій має ними
проведена бути велика робота навіть до
початку
реєстрації в єдиному реєстрі досудових
розслідувань тобто до відкриття
кримінального провадження беб має
зібрати достатньо доказів і інформації і
не діяти просто так на обум а можливо
там щось в ході розслідування вискочить
і тоді не треба буде проводити обшуки як
зараз проводяться з приходять на
підприємство вивертають все зі столів
керівництва е менеджерів підприємства
для того щоби щось знайти ні при зміні
роботи якщо і будуть е дозволені такі
обшуки то це буде предметом дока пошуку
доказів чи виїмки доказів щодо
здійснення певних правопорушень не мо
Оце те що ми називаємо маски-шоу
маске-шоу - це коли забігли і говорять
всім лягти і вигрібають все зі столів і
на столах і всю техніку забирають Ну ми
повернулися до
2013 року це точно Ви сказали тому що з
цим боротися насправді важко
перебудувати роботу правоохоронців важко
но ми ж змогли це зробити і зараз так
швидко поламали роботу яка
налагоджувалася яка була спрямована на
розуміння і на
дуже інтелігентного не знаю дружнього
відношення до бізнесу бізнес і держава -
це дві сторони які тримають взагалі весь
державний устрій тому коли ми говоримо
що як має бути зміна інституціональна
зміна роботи беп то вони мають
запровадити єдину унікальну
методологію яка забезпечує економічну
безпеку яка якою користується беб
податкова і митниця тому що це три
органи які залишаться в роботі з
платниками податків і цю методику має
знати бізнес не треба нічого ховати від
бізнесу не треба робити такі заходи щоб
потім ось ми щось розробили щоб ударити
в спину бізнесу бізнес партнер держави і
тому мені здається що
якщо нас підтримують з тими ініціативами
які тільки що продемонстрував Петро
Олексійович то насправді ми будемо тоді
всі сили докладати щоби далі рухатися по
шляху подальших змін саме інституційних
змін які потрібні для роботи бюро
економічної безпеки тільки тоді ми
будемо говорити що щось буде змінюватися
і Тому ніякі зустрічі додаткові ніякі
вирішення от знову створити Раду бізнесу
при на якісь там площадці Скажіть будь
ласка ну який резутати
інвестняню на іх хто гасить Інвест
пожежу на Інвест пожежників але має
захищати закон аж ні в якому ні разі
інвестяні
інвестпожежники ради підприємстві або
Шульга там чи Шурма чи як його там з
рештою Тобто це механізм має працювати
інституційний інакше бізнес сюди не
прийде Я Хочу
наголосити одну дуже важливу
позиція Україна може профінансована бути
партнерами за рахунок коштів публічних
фінансів тобто бюджетів наших
країн-партнерів Великої сімки євросоюза
Сполучених Штатів лише на
20%.
80% - це абсолютно чітка оцінка наших
партнерів мають бути прямі іноземні
інвестиції з таким іноземни з таким
інвестиційним кліматом нені прийде ніхто
бо це підрив довіри довіри до
української влади довіри до силовиків
яки її зараз немає і головне довіри до
нашої держави а от цього ми допустити аж
ніяк не можемо Я хотіла би все все ж
таки підкреслити що можливо такі
площадки
депре присутні представники як рада
бізнесу - це якісь консультаційні
розмови поради напрацювання на майбутнє
але точно це не вирішення величезних
проблем які на сьогодні є в нашому
суспільстві щодо тиску на бізнес і тому
абсолютно точно Я закликаю просто всіх
силовиків набратися сили волі і всупереч
всьому виконувати І на сьогодні діючі
норми кримінального процесуального
кодексу тому що все що тут було
запропоновано тільки їх посилює вдвічі
втричі Хоча як якби у нас працювала і
була правова держава То того що є на
сьогодні рішення ра безпеки Це просто
навести Да уже того би не складалося
тому вибачте як робити
аудит вжитих захо обмежувальних захдів
заходів у кримінальних провадженнях як
визначити е інформацію яку треба там а
або коло питань які треба
призупинити слухайте це означає що
країнасилювати беб тобто вони вважають
що беб у нас зараз слабкий і відповідно
до рішення ради його треба посилювати Це
точно дорога в неправильному напрямку це
якщо вчитатися в слова які написані в
цьому рішенні це саме так і означає тут
якраз приділено зовсім мало уваги
бізнесу А якщо чесно то зовсім нічого
тому наші пропозиції - це насправді дія
а дія призведе до результату а не
розмови так і будемо рухатися Слава
Україні Героям слава Героям слава
дякуємо дякуємо колеги Дякую за
увагу
найкраще